so air travel is a disaster under the
man who's supposed to fix air travel but
it's not just air travel
have you written on a train recently
have you really have you done a train
well on Monday of this week at 5 PM
passengers in Virginia got on an Amtrak
Bound for Orlando the car train they're
supposed to arrive by 10 a.m on Tuesday
but they didn't
instead they were stuck on that train
for 37 hours because Amtrak part of our
transportation system could not figure
out how to navigate around a derailment
some passengers called the police
thinking they've been taken hostage
once again for those of you that are
calling the police
we are not holding you uh [ __ ] we are
giving you all the information in which
we have we are sorry about the
inconvenient
as far as more information is available
we will let you know shortly
thank you
we'd like you to know that we're not
holding you hostage
we have all the information quote in
which we have
excuse me that's our transportation
system it's probably not funny if you
were caught on that train Colleen
McKenna was she's one of The Travelers
who was stuck on a stinking Amtrak train
for 37 hours Colleen I'm sorry to laugh
it must have been horrible thank you for
joining us tonight what was that like
it was honestly
it was extremely frustrating just
because of the lack of information from
Amtrak
um I woke up about 6 a.m on Tuesday and
we were stopped in North Carolina and I
spoke with one of my attendants and he
just said that there was a derail I
never talked about train in front of us
so we're gonna have to take a detour I
have no idea when we're going to arrive
in Sanford my best guess is later on
this evening
so they just had no idea what was going
on the entire time
now trains and correct me if I'm wrong
but they're on tracks right they can't
just Veer off into the woods and get
lost I mean they run on metal rails
so yeah right so at least that's the way
it used to work how could a train not
have quote information about where it's
going
I don't know at one point
um we moved to South Carolina and we
were stuck there for six hours they told
us that they needed to switch over Crews
and one should be arriving at around 5
30. 5 30 came around and we got an
update and they said that they're unsure
where this crew is and they don't know
when we're going to be here
so the next update we got was around
seven o'clock where they said it'd be
two more hours for them to get to us
were you heartened or confused when they
announced on the PA system that they
were quote not holding you hostage
I thought it was funny but I did
understand people's concern because
there was no way off of the train
um we were stuck in the middle of
nowhere in South Carolina and there
wasn't an option to go outside so we
were locked in but I didn't feel unsafe
did anyone try to make a break for it
not that I'm aware of but it could have
been possible
hmm so I have to ask and you don't have
to answer this if you don't want because
it's a sensitive question but there's
been a lot of concern uh about racism
misogyny and transphobia in our
transportation system did you notice any
of those things on the Amtrak train
I didn't
um I was a little isolated on the train
just because I had a private room so the
most interaction I got was when I was
having my meals but when I was around
other people I didn't notice anything
significant okay well I think people the
judge is going to count that as a win uh
so I appreciate your coming on I'm glad
you're off the train Colleen I'm glad
you weren't held hostage thank you so
much I'm glad I'm here thank you